JM: Hello! My name is Jam.
JM: I'm tester with fable. and today we will be doing recorded goose sighting.
JM: which is slug number UOCI, RGS. One.
JM: I'm a screen reader user, I'm using the Nvd a screen reader on windows 10.
JM: And the latest version of Google Chrome to perform this test. The purpose of the test is to
JM: record information about a goose sighting that I might have had.
JM: and to fill out the fields as well as explore the links on the page.
JM: and also to review my input and make a change. So with all that said, I'm going to begin on the page.
link, skip to main content.
JM: So there's my first link, right link, skip to main content that should take me to the
JM: main area of the page. But I'm going to go past it for now and see what else is here. This is not a real government service, and you'll have to create your own way of registering geese. Sorry.
JM: Okay. List with 3 items, link home
link, environment and countries, link, wildlife and biodiversity out of list, main landmark heading level one record agus siting. Use this service to list with 3. Item bullet. Tell us what type of goose you saw
bullet. The date on which you saw the goose out of list. Button start now.
JM: Complementary lens. So
JM: that's the way the important stuff on the page right there. So before we begin starting. Yeah, begin with the the process. I'm going to test out the slightly links list with 3 items, home link.
environment and home link.
JM: skip to main content. Main landmark heading level, one record a goose sighting. So the skip to main content like works out of list, use the service to list with 3 items bullet out of list with environment, wildlife and biodiversity link.
Pat: So
JM: so what I'm doing now is, I'm hitting the tab key to go through the different links. There are not very many of them on the pitch. Main landmark. Start now, button.
Start now. Button list with 3 items, wildlife and biodiversity link
JM: so wildlife and biodiversity, cookie, banner, landmark, clickable navigation. Men open 2 different tabs, wildlife and biodivers which take me away from the page.
JM: But start page. It seems like the links are working well. So I'm going to start the field entry now out Mainlandmark. Start now, button
JM: busy, link, skip to main content mainland. I found the button
JM: start now by using the navigation elements
JM: finding the one button that I remember seeing on the page which was for starting.
JM: and so all I had to do was hit the letter B, and it took me right to the button, which is great. Now I'm going to explore this page. Select. Yes, if you like. These
radio button not checked.
JM: Yes, radio button.
Continue button
JM: grouping. Select. Yes, skip to main content like no, there's only one, I guess. I guess we're going to be just filling out things and clicking. Continue. Probably. So
JM: here we just have radio button, no radio button check. Yes, radio button checked one of 2. I don't actually know anything about these. But I'm going to say, yes. So
JM: toolbar view site, information document Mainlandmark grouping, select. Yes, if you like these. Yes. Radio button checked toolbar view site, information, address, document, Mainlandmark grouping, select. Yes, if skip to main content, link.
main landmark grouping select. Yes, if you like these. Yes, radio button checked one of 2
JM: toolbar view site information. So there is a continue
JM: button or link. But for some reason the tab key is not hitting it, but I know it's there.
JM: so hang on a minute while Doc find it. But no radio button.
JM: Yes, radio, but no radio. Yes. Radio button checked one. Yes. Radio, no radio tool. Okay.
address and search view site, information menu document, main landmark grouping, select. Yesip. toolbar.
mainlandmark toolbar.
JM: Alright. So for some reason, I'm getting stuck here and I'm not really sure why document Mainlandmark grouping select. Yes, if you yes. Radio button checked one of no. Yes. Radio toolbar view site, information.
document, mainland.
JM: Yes, radio button. No button. Continue. Okay. So I don't know what happened there. But for some reason I was stuck in the
JM: a
JM: focus mode, and it wouldn't go out of it to find a continue button. So I had to manually switch out of it.
JM: And now I'm able to hit the continued button
boop record a goose sighting busy link, skip to main content. Main landmark heading level one. What type of goose did you see ghost goose? Tell us what type of goose it was? Edit blacks, per-winged goose button. Continue.
JM: Okay, so what kind of goose is it? Skip to toolbar, address.
boop, mainland, mark, ghost, goose.
Tell us what type of goose it was. Edit blacks per winged goose, blank.
JM: blank blank. Okay, so I have to enter in something. So I'll enter in
JM: Canada, Canada. Bruce
boost. Continue button. When did you see the goose record? A goose siding, busy link, skip to main content. Main landmark grouping, heading level one. When did you see the goose?
JM: For example? 16, 4, 2,017 day, edit. Month, edit. Year. Edit out of grouping button. Okay? So
JM: there are 3 different fields for the entry of the date. Skip to main content. Month. Edit day edit blank. So I'm going to answer in 20
20 month. Edit. Blank
JM: 9 0 9 year. Edit. Blank.
JM: 20, 31,
2031. Continue. Button.
JM: check your answers. Record a goose sighting busy link, skip to main content. Main landmark heading level. One. Check your answers before sending your application. Heading level 3. I thought he was going to complain about me picking a date in the future. But apparently it's this is what I'm supposed to be seeing. So
JM: let's see, heading level one, check your answers before sending your application.
Heading. Level 3 goose details. List with 9 items. You like these. Yes, link change biscuits. Type of goose that you saw Canada goose link, change cake.
JM: Okay, I'm going to change this response. Now.
boop record a goose sighting link, skip to main content. Main landmark heading level one. What type of goose did you see? Ghost, goose, main landmark? Tell us what type of goose?
When did you see the main skip to main content. Main landmark. When did you see the goose
JM: grouping, for example? 16 4. Skipped toolbar?
JM: alright! So I hit answer by mistake, and it took me
JM: to the next screen. So
JM: don't remember seeing a back button main landmark. So I'm going to actually use the browser back button. And hopefully it'll work.
Continue, button.
JM: Tell us what type of goose it was. Edit black.
JM: It did work. So
JM: now I'm going to do what I'm supposed to do and change it. I don't really know what type of piece there are. So I'm just gonna enter in a silly answer and say. I saw a mongoose
mongoose. Continue button.
JM: When did you see the goose record? A goose sighting link, skip to main content? So now I can change this as well. Main landmark. When did you see the month, year, edit, blank
JM: month edit blank? Ok, it seems to have cleared my date answer. So I'm gonna have to re. Answer that
day. Edit. Blank
24, 0 9 year, edit. 2031. Continue. But check your answers. Record a goose sighting busy link, skip to main heading level. 3 goose details. List with 9. Yes.
link change biscuit type of goose that you saw. Mongoose Linkchaint date. You saw the goose 24, slash, 0, 9, slash, 2031 link. Change fdate out of list. Heading. Level 2. Now send your application.
By submitting this notification. You are confirming that to the best of your knowledge, the details you are providing are correct.
Button collapsed. What happens with my data button? Continue.
JM: Okay, there's no check box. So what happens with my data? But list with not what happens with my data button collapsed.
JM: maybe I should look at that
expanded nothing. This doesn't actually do or collect anything. You unfortunately.
JM: okay, Button continue. So I'm going to continue
goose recorded. Record a goose sighting busy https, slash link, skip to main mainlandmark goose recorded head. Your reference number
HDJ. 2123 F. We have received your goose-related information unlabelled, graphic to get missing image descriptions open the context. Menu
heading level 2 finished the accessibility exercise. If you think you've found all the accessibility issues, link, take a look at the answers dot
JM: or link record another goose sighting. Ok, I believe that's the end of the flow. So I have successfully recorded a mongoose sighting or a Canada goose siting.
JM: and I think overall that works pretty well. There was some weird hiccup with the radio buttons at the beginning, and I don't know if that was the site or Nvda or me.
JM: but I was able to clear it pretty quickly just by going manually into browse mode
the other thing was I didn't expect the
JM: data for the date field to be cleared.
JM: I don't really think that's an accessibility issue. But it's just something that I wasn't really expecting to happen.
JM: and so luckily I read the info that the field was now blank, so just re-entered it, and there's only 3 screens to fill out anyway. So
JM: overall, the experience was very positive, and I would definitely use this if I were recording these. So thank you very much for caring about accessibility.